نتابع تقييم هذه التطورات معنا من عمان
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اللواء فايز
الدويري لواء فايز تقييمكم للتكتيكات التي
تعتمدها المقاومه الفلسطينيه تارت تركز
قصفها على غلاف اخرى على غلاف غزه واخرى
تصل الى العمق الاسرائيلي
يعني هناك العديد من الملاحظات على اداره
المعركه منهما هو ايجابي ومنها ما هو سلبي
لنبدا بالبعد الايجابي البعد الايجابي
تمثل بمقاربه مختلفه كليا عن الحروب الخمس
الماضيه حيث اولا التزم الصمت الى تقريبا
30 ساعه وجعل القياده الاسرائيليه
السياسيه والعسكريه والمجتمع الاسرائيلي
في مرحله ترقب وانتظار لما سيحدث وحتى
قامت اسرائيل بمحاولات استفزاز انجازت
التسميه من اجل الاسراع في الرد لتحديد
اتجاه بوصله العمليه الان المقاربه لا
تزال يمر ساعات من الهدوء والترقب ومن ثم
يتم اطلاق الصواريخ التركيز بصوره رئيسيه
على غلاف غزه علما ان الدائره التي فرضتها
اسرائيل على الشعب الاسرائيلي والمجتمع
الاسرائيلي تمتد الى 80
متر من الملاحظ على
اداره المعركه انها فضلت في هذه المره
التركيز على غلاف غزه وكانت مقله في
التعامل مع العمق الاسرائيلي كان هناك
جنوب
تل ابيب سقط صاروخ قتل شخص واصابه 13
جريحا بالامس كان هناك مقاربه في منطقه
عطسيون وكانت احدثت نوع من الارباك
والبلبله ولم يكن هناك تاثير واضح
لسلاح مقاومه الدبابات كما جرى في الامور
السابقه
فايز يعني توضيحا لماذا كانت يعني ما هو
المعيار التي على اساسها يمكن ان نقيم هل
هو عدد الصواريخ التي تسقط في هذه المناطق
ام وصول مدى الصواريخ التي وصلت اليها بغض
النظر عن العدد يعني وصلت الى جنوبي القدس
وجنوبي تل ابيب رمزيه هذه المناطق اهميتها
البعد عن قطاع غزه
كمحلل ومتابع
شاركت في التحليل للاربعه حروب السابقه
اقول ان سقوط صاروخ في عمق فلسطين المحتله
على مقربه من مطار اللد ما يطلق عليه بن
غوريون او على مقربه من القدس او يصل الى
اطرافه تل ابيب سقوط صاروخ واحد وحتى ان
نزل في ارض فارغه سيكون تاثيره على القرار
السياسي حول اسراع انهاء العمليات
العسكريه اكثر من عشرات الصواريخ التي
تسقط في غلاف غزه نجاحهم في اطلاق صاروخ
كورنيت على عربه مقاتله واصابتها يسرع في
انهاء العمليات اذا هنا انا اتحدث عن
اهميه ونوعيه الهدف وامكانيه الوصول اله
حتى هو في بعض الحالات انفشل هذا الصاروخ
فقط ان يكون عندما نتحدث عن دائره تمتد
الى اطراف تل ابيب وتغطي القدس نحن تحدث
عن اكثر من سبعه الى ثمانيه مليون من
المجتمع الاسرائيلي يكون رهينه
للمقاربه المقاومه بينما اذا كان في في
اطار غزه والمستوطنات الان التوجيه تم
التزام البيوت التزام الملاجئ وتعطيل
الدراسه تحديد الحركه اذا دعيني اقول صانع
القرار صانع القرار السياسي لديه حريه
مناوره في حال عدم استهداف العمق اكثر من
حال استهداف فقط غلاف غزه لكن لو سمحتي لي
نقطه واحده
تفضل انا تحدثت عن السلبيه سلبيه اداره
المعركه السؤال الذي لم اجد له اجابه كيف
تم
اقتناص سته من رموز القادم من الصف الاول
قد يكون هناك تقبل ان يقتل ثلاثه منهم في
فجر العمليه لانها كانت مفاجئه لكن كيف تم
اصطياد اثنين اخرين وبالامس اصطياد مدير
العمليات وجميعهم في مشاكل المنطق يقول ان
منذ لحظه انطلاق العمليه كافه القياديين
والذي لهم دور كبير في اداره المعركه هذا
يكون غزي مدينه الانفاق بها انفاق دفاعيه
انفاق هجوميه انفاق للقياده والسيطره
انفاق لاداره العمليات كيف ذهب ولما ذهب
الى هذه المنازل انا لا املك الاجابه ولكن
تفاجات بسرعه اقتناص سته
الجهاد الاسلامي من الصف الاول طيب فيما
يتعلق بتقييمكم للقبه الحديديه عاده ما
كان يعلن في الجولات السابقه عن انها نجحت
بنسبه سته وتسعين في المئه وسبعه وتسعين
في المئه في هذه المره يتم الاعلان عن
انها نجحت بنسبه
92% بتقديرك ما هو السبب هل يعود الى
مشاكل تقنيه فنيه ام الى تطور تكتيكات
المقاومه الفلسطينيه
يعني اولا رقم 96 ورقم 92 غير دقيق وهذا
الرقم لا يعتد به وهو من اجل تمرير نجاحها
ولدينا الكثير من الاعمال والابحاث وغيره
من الباحثين المتخصصين بالفيزياء النوويه
في يدور ريستل تحدث عن عشره بالميه انا
تحدثت عن ستين الى
75% ليس اكثر من ذلك لكن اسرائيل لا تصرع
حقيقه بعدد الصواريخ التي تم اسقاطها
لماذا لان نظام عملها نظام عملها هناك
نظام المتابعه والتحكم عندما يكون الصاروخ
متجه الى ارض فارغه لا يتم اعتراضه عندما
يتم اسقاط الصاروخ انا اعتبر انه من ضمن
النسبه في دور ريستل لا يعتبر ذلك لماذا
لانه اسقاط الصاروخ جراء اصابه
جسم الصاروخ يسقط الصاروخ والراس لا يزال
فاعلا ويمكن ان ينفجر لذلك هو يتحدث عن
التدمير وانا اتحدث عن الاسقاط لكن هناك
نجاح في اداء المقاومه وهذا النجاح يتمثل
في العديد من الاجراءات منها اولا الاطلاق
بزوايا مختلفه اطلاق صواريخ متنوعه من حيث
السرعه والارتفاع وزوايا الاقتراب سواء
كانت عموديه اوجا او جانبيه يضاف الى ذلك
تزويد بعض الصواريخ بفيوزات وهميه فنجحت
المقاومه في تقليل درجه نجاح القبه
الحديديه في اسقاط الصواريخ وليس تدميرها
اذا ذهبنا الى التدمير نتحدث عن اصطدام
الراس بالراس وهذا يجب ان تكون نقطه
المقاربه لا تتجاوز 1 متر حتى شظايا
الصاروخ القبه الحديديه يفجر الصاروخ
الاخر لكن لناخذ فقط بالاسقاط انا اقول لم
يصل الى مستوى 75% شكرا لك فايزه ادواريك
كنت معنا من عمان